for quite a long time the sort of
adopted agreed definition for the edge
of space has been something called the
carmen line
which is located at 100 kilometers above
the earth's surface it is not a legal
definition but it's a definition that's
been adopted by the federation
international aeronautic which is the
world air sports federation but it's
it's a largely unsatisfying definition
because of course the atmosphere doesn't
have an edge it's a continuous
fluid body it has lots of different
properties in lots of different regions
but none of them have rigidly defined
edges and in fact the properties change
as a function of time and solar activity
and lots of other things 100 seems
almost too perfect doesn't it it does so
recently a paper's been published called
the edge of space revisiting the carmen
line and this was work done by an
astrophysicist named jonathan mcdowell
at the harvard smithsonian center for
astrophysics and he takes a closer look
into whether there is a real scientific
definition for the karman line the
original carmen line definition was
roughly associated with the idea that
there's a boundary between
where aeronautical forces stop and you
no longer get lift in the atmosphere
aeronautical lift is a mechanical force
it's generated by contact with the fluid
the fluid obviously being the atmosphere
and if you run out of fluid you run out
of force and so at the carbon line it
you're you're sort of where an aircraft
would have to travel at a speed that's
greater than the orbital velocity
in order to get enough lift from its
wings to stay in the air so in this
paper we looked at the orbits of 43 000
satellites have been tracked over the
years and of course most of them are way
above the karman line but there were
substantial numbers that throughout
their orbit would pass below the 100
kilometer line getting even closer to 80
kilometers and not just on their last
orbit before they disintegrated but they
had multiple passages this low and so
right away you can say okay well the 100
kilometer line doesn't make a lot of
sense you can't have a satellite in
orbit and then it comes in and oh for a
little bit it's not in space and then it
goes back into space and and on and on
and on and so right there is some
evidence to at least support the idea of
revisiting this definition so the second
thing he did was actually use an
atmospheric model and actually make the
calculations of for a typical satellite
where would the drag forces
um be enough to sort of cause it to fall
back to earth so like the death zone
the death stone for satellites that's
exactly it so the conclusion he makes is
that for a typical kind of space vehicle
the gravity will exceed the aerodynamic
forces for any object in steady flight
at that altitude that altitude lies in
about the 70 to 90 kilometer range so he
factors in the time variation and all of
this stuff and and finds a range for
this limit but notes that it's always
well below that 100 kilometer line this
is just one argument other arguments
would look at the structure of the
atmosphere which is quite complicated
but again it's divided into specific
layers
mostly
based on where the gradient in
temperature changes these are called
pauses and so at about 85 kilometers
we've got the mesopause which is the
boundary between the mesosphere and the
thermosphere and that marks the point
which is the coldest point in the
atmosphere below that point
the chemical pump position of the
atmosphere is mostly steady and above
that you've got different molecules
moving in different ways and so from
atmospheric physics there's also a
boundary more towards the 80 kilometer
line so what's really interesting about
this argument is to actually appreciate
how close space is because 80 kilometers
100 kilometers that's not that far away
you can easily drive that in an hour
so i thought it might be fun to look on
a map and actually appreciate um to
scale how how how far away space is of
course our map is centered on the center
of the universe which is here in
nottingham and the unit that we're going
to use to mark scale on this map
is the humble lego block the height of
this brick is 3.2 millimeters and so
i've printed this map so that five of
these lego bricks
represent 100 kilometers on this map to
put some things into scale first let's
talk about airliners so when we're on a
commercial airliner we're traveling at
about an altitude of 10 to 12 kilometers
so when we're traveling on a commercial
airline we're not even traveling at the
height of this brick above this map so
the next scale i'm going to show you is
the world record for how high a human
being has jumped out of a balloon to
skydive down to earth so this record was
broken recently by alan eustis
and he jumped from a height of 41
kilometers so that would represent two
bricks on this map and so now we want to
go up to the karman line and so the
debate we're discussing today is whether
we define the edge of space at 80
kilometers which is here
or 100 kilometers which is
here doesn't seem that hard anyway does
it so i think that's the amazing thing
uh to appreciate so if this height is a
hundred kilometers what's really amazing
is how small this number actually is how
close we are to space so if i tip this
on this the edge and i've got 100
kilometer marker here you can see that
nottingham is closer to space than it is
to london and i can get that london in
an hour and a half on the train all
right so maybe nottingham to london
doesn't mean very much to you but if you
you're in new york you're closer to
space than you are to philadelphia
if you're in los angeles you're closer
to space than you are to san diego oh
let me do a canadian one okay
if you're in montreal you're closer to
space than you are to ottawa
i've got no idea where those places are
all right cool i looked up adelaide for
you but nothing's near adelaide so it
didn't work when do you become an
astronaut so
nasa gives its astronaut wings to anyone
who's trained and flown a successful
mission that reaches above 50 miles
which is 80 kilometers so that's
actually the lower limit and there's a
similar acknowledgement from the us
for civilians who have piloted a
successful flight above that line is
this important like is this just a bunch
of people writing papers or does it
matter where space starts and finishes
so
it it matters from a scientific
perspective because scientists like to
study these sorts of things so it's
perfectly understandable that people who
are interested in
atmospheric physics and the orbits of
satellites would care but it it actually
does have some wider issues that now
touch on issues of economics and
politics and defense and things like
that
so i mentioned there is no international
agreed legal definition of space there
have been for some time moves to make a
legal definition
but that's always been opposed by the
u.s
and you can understand why because from
a military point of view a government
wouldn't want to be restricted by
international space treaties
when it's trying to launch high altitude
ballistic missiles something like that
and what about space tourism i guess
they want it to be as low as possible so
they can sell their space flights well
that's the other issue so commercial
space tourism is becoming a thing now as
we film this virgin galactic has just
managed to pilot a vehicle to 82
kilometers by the nasa definition that
counts as entering space by the fai
definition it doesn't because they
haven't reached the karman line but it
would matter very very much to a
commercial enterprise to be able to
say that they can take people into space
now practically speaking
you know i think what you would want
from a space mission is the experience
of weightlessness and the experience of
looking out the window and seeing the
earth as a as a ball you would get that
from 80 kilometers as well as you would
from 100 kilometers but like i look at
that and i look at how low that is and i
imagine how come you can see the
curvature of the earth from such a that
doesn't seem that high i think partly
that's because i've printed a map out on
a flat piece of paper so in reality this
is a curved surface that i'm showing you
here you might not see it as a complete
ball but you would definitely see the
curvature of the earth you would
experience the earth as a sphere it
becomes
quite clear that for commercial
enterprise you're not going to want to
waste money and fuel and
increase risk by taking people up to 100
kilometers if they can get the same
experience going to 80 kilometers
but part of that experience for people
will be able will be being able to say i
have officially been to space where
would you be drawing the line well i'm
pretty convinced by this paper i mean it
has some pretty sound arguments from a
number of different directions so i
think if there was a move to redefine
the 80 kilometer line as the mcdowell
line i think that should go down very
well but but mcdowell says 70 to 90.
that's like super vague
well that's just because scientists you
you know scientists you've talked to
enough of us over the years and we like
our arab bars and we like our confidence
intervals but if you want to define a
line you might as well put it in the
middle of a region that is well-bounded
this paper has revisited the numbers and
the back of the envelope calculations
that gave 100
are now refined and they might not give
a more precise number but they at least
show us that it's not a hundred and so
it's
very unsatisfying to keep it at that
level i thought it would be fun to
actually build up a perspective on the
altitude that other objects in space get
part of this was motivated by the fact
that just last week i went outside as i
was coming home from work and happened
to see the international space station
go overhead it was really bright it was
a beautiful passage and as always i was
struck by looking up and thinking
oh my god there's human beings flying
above my head in orbit around the earth
that's pretty amazing how far away are
they actually up there the space shuttle
now no longer in existence but i
couldn't resist getting my lego out i
used to take astronauts up to the
international space station like may
jameson and that's at 400 kilometers
above the surface of the earth
so in
our lego bricks if this is a hundred we
need four times that amount
so
let's
do this 13
14
16 i feel like i'm on lego masters
20. excellent right so this is the orbit
at which human beings continuously
inhabit a space station orbiting the
earth
and even that is not that high i'm
slightly less impressed
that wasn't your goal was it
i think one of the values of human space
flight one of the real values is
cultural not scientific
and it's putting human beings high
enough to give them that perspective on
space
and if they only have to go that high
to be able to look out in one direction
and see nothing but the infinity of
space and then turn around and look down
and see the earth
in
enough scope
to see
not borders and not resources to be
exploited but to appreciate that this is
the one and only place where life in the
universe exists and to look out to the
horizon and appreciate
how razor thin that precious atmosphere
that keeps us safe is
then i think i think it's quite amazing
that you don't have to get that high up
to find a perspective where you realize
just how precarious and how delicate the
ecosystem and the geosystem on earth is
what else you want to show me you got
hubble there or okay so i've got uh
nancy roman and the hubble space
telescope one of my favorites
and this orbits at an altitude of 540
kilometers it used to be higher but it's
slowly even at that altitude it suffers
from accumulative
atmospheric drag over time so it's going
lower and lower and that represents
pretty much the highest altitude that
the space shuttle could reach because it
was hubble was designed to be put into
earth orbit at an altitude where the
space shuttle could repeatedly go and
service it and it's a good thing it did
because we benefited from those
servicing missions quite a lot and so
i've got 20 bricks now and i need to put
eight more to get up to the height of
the hubble space telescope so
one
two
three
five
now we've run out of thin bricks so
we're gonna put
three more on top and so that's how high
the hubble space telescope is
all right so there's the hubble space
telescope yeah there you go success not
to scale of course the whole space
telescope is about the size of the bus
not about the width of the united
kingdom what's higher than that well
there's lots of satellites up there in
orbit gps global positioning satellites
orbit at an altitude of 20 000
kilometers above the surface of the
earth that would require a thousand lego
bricks and i'm not going to build that
today
but i would just note that that would
take us 3.2 meters
above this map
okay so right through the ceiling up
there somewhere okay and these are
satellites they're in geosynchronous
orbits so they orbit the earth twice a
day but there are satellites that are
even further up they're called
geostationary orbits their orbital
period is matched with the rotation of
the earth so they orbit once a day which
means that they are effectively always
above the same location
above the equator and these are the
satellites that give us our weather meet
readings and our active our
communications relays on this scale
you'd need
1789 bricks which would take you 5.7
meters above
the table
all right well that's way up way up
we're looking here down at the uk and
europe how many bricks down is the other
side of the earth so i said that the gps
satellites are at a thousand bricks
above the earth um but the other side of
the earth would only be 640 bricks so
that's less than the height of the gps
satellites what about what if i wanted
to go to the moon of course you want to
go to the moon well you would need to
travel 19
220
lego bricks away which on this scale
would be 60 meters there's been enough
recent attention to this idea that the
karmann line needs to be redefined that
the organizations that deal with
aeronautical things and the organization
that deals with astronautical things are
proposing to get together in the coming
year to have a symposium to look at the
scientific and the political and
whatever other arguments go into this to
see if we need to actually have a
definition of where is space and what
that might be we made a video a couple
years ago saying voyagers left the solar
system and just left the solar system
again so most things in space don't have
a hard edge and that means that
different definitions can apply
and you can argue to until the cows come
home about whether pluto's a planet or
where the solar system ends or how big
is the milky way and to some extent you
will never get a satisfying answer
because
science often comes with caveats that
say it depends what you mean
i can tilt it but you'll notice that the
axis of the spin keeps pointing the same
direction it explains things but the
main thing it does is creates a huge
problem
because if you're a theoretical
physicist you can do a calculation that
says okay so i'm creating all these
virtual particles